next step get your instagram feed fired
up because we've got an account that you
must follow unilad reports that this
photographer captures incredible freeze
frames of dogs catching treats
okay the photographer is christian velar
and he's been taking these action shots
for years and i gotta tell you this is
exactly what i look like when my post
mates are on
that's what i would look like at the
barbecue place eating the ribs totally
absolutely with the ex-boyfriend who's
got a bloated sense of self and thinks
it's all about him this is so cute you
know like
imagine how many outtakes he has because
you ever tried to take a picture of your
dog for like a christmas card or
something and getting the it's just
impossible
yeah it's me with the kids i'm taking
pictures of us all the time and it's
like maybe one a year do i get that's
like semi-passable yeah here's a tip if
you're taking a picture of your dog get
a squeaky toy and squeak it like oh
that's cute yeah well maybe you should
follow christian velar and throw treats
and like i mean those pictures are just
joy yeah and this is an instagram
account that's gonna truly boost my life
i mean that's a lot of what instagram is
about is to give you some information
show you beautiful art news information
but just come across something that just
makes you smile and this one does it for
me well
i don't
i don't follow christian yet but you
know what i'm going to throw you a bone
i'm going to follow you yeah
all right hey i love this next story it
comes all the way from poland apartment
therapy reports a group there is trying
to fight loneliness with something
called happy to chat benches
are these benches they're special and
they've been installed in public parks
they encourage a connection between
strangers instructions are printed right
there on the bench it says sit here if
you don't mind stopping to say hello now
it's like you're you're forrest gump
fantasy if you're feeling a little
lonely and you want to sit down and just
meet a stranger
find somebody else get a glimpse in a
window into somebody else's life this is
the bench for you and i love things that
are designated areas to meet people it's
why i love singles nights at bars
because it's like go here everyone's in
the mood to meet somebody well on this
bench you can meet your next best friend
i love this i really do
when i i lived on my own for in my first
apartment when i was 14
and i wasn't able to drive and i lived
in los angeles which is not a walking
city and sometimes i would take the bus
and um i had just read this book called
desiderata and it had this caption in it
that said listen to people for they have
their stories too
and
when i read that i felt so in love with
it it changed my life and i was riding
the bus a lot
so a bus bench was a great place for me
to hear people's stories and strike up
conversations that's so cute and you
know what i feel like you do that on
this show every day if we meet people we
find their stories and we're inspired by
them every single day and i would
encourage anybody out there in any city
where you're watching this put a bench
like this in your park and just see what
happens oh yes very nodding hell by the
way oh my god
[Music]
you